hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga so long as it's that one
particular anime under manga because we
are back with more hunter hunter and
much more specifically to continue the
encyclopedia where today it is time to
focus on one of the most deceptively
simple yet terrifying nen wielders in
this entire series hisoka moro because
yes that's right hisoka does indeed have
a last name which is moro
very strange and plain it's kind of like
giving the joker a last name and having
it be smith but hisoka is an iconic
pillar of non-ant related hunter hunter
and as such he's also one of the most
pronounced non-users of the series in
fact i think you'd be quite hard-pressed
to find inability that is more
well-known than hisoka's bungee gum
which
as the meme states contains the
properties of both rubber
and gum the fact that i just so happen
to get reminded of in every single video
i make but that's alright because jokes
are eternal and they never get old and
you know what else never gets old me
telling you to subscribe to the new
world review which will result in
regular hunt hunt content being uploaded
straight into your youtube feed because
it contains the properties of both
pressing the fun button and joining our
very own hunter association
and please do comment down below if you
are a new member and hisoka welcomes you
warmly so before we get into bungies and
gums though hisoka is a notable figure
for possessing what i would call the
perfect set of prerequisites for aura
control he comes equipped with
superhuman levels of strength speed and
endurance which are on par if not even
greater than that of painstakingly
trained assassins such as ilmizoldic in
addition to that he is also a generalist
master when it comes to both
hand-to-hand combat and even wielding
weaponry the second of which doesn't
occur
all that often but when it does hisoka
demonstrates an almost surgical level of
precision favoring blades in particular
but where hisoka becomes truly
devastating is his genius level
intellect it's sometimes very difficult
to reconcile the intelligence of this
man primarily because he tends to act
solely for very primal desires but
hisoka is capable of out thinking
all but the highest level strategist of
this world and what's more impressive is
that he can do this in a purely
improvised manner so as a result hisoka
fits very nicely into the mental tier of
characters such as krolo jing and
paristan
all of whom are identified by their
intellect rather than raw output and i
go to the trouble of laying all of this
ground working stuff because hisoka is a
natural transmuter one of the more
cerebral branches of nenus which allows
wielders to change the properties of
their aura to mimic real world
substances
or in most cases even augment or create
their own new substance
it's not a particularly well balanced
nang category and when it comes to
transmuters you will either see a master
class of nenus or a complete and utter
failure there is no in between and
obviously hisoka falls more on the
master class side of things and with
that we should probably get into the
first if here's two
countum 2 hansu being the infamous
bungee gun this ability is probably one
of the most
underwhelming in all of hunter hunter
when you first hear it explained because
basically it allows hisoka to transmute
hizora into a sticky and elastic
substance
and that's yeah that's pretty much it i
mean yes the aura is impossibly sticky
and nigh on impenetrable but there's no
you know summoning giant deities no
complex mathematics and no string of
absurd conditions or restrictions used
to create overwhelming power in fact
it's kind of ironically mind-boggling
considering just how simple bungee gum
is especially for someone at hisoka's
level because having no restrictions or
conditions is a
massive advantage but then again i
suppose that's not necessarily true
because the restriction is that bunge
gum is honestly
nothing all that special it doesn't have
a very high aura cost it doesn't do
anything stupidly overpowered and really
the only reason why it's a threat in any
way shape or form is because it's in the
hands of one of the greatest geniuses
that hunter hunter has ever known bungie
gum is not an ability that can stand on
its own and it serves primarily to
augment hisoka because at his core he is
a hand-to-hand fighter
so an example of how he may commonly use
bungee gun would be to attach elastic
strand to the roof of an enclosed base
and should he need to swiftly dodge an
attack he will allow the elasticity to
pull him out of harm's way or as an
offensive measure he can pretty much do
the exact same thing to an opponent
attach a strand of aura to them and
forcibly pull the opponent towards him
usually resulting in much pain and in
many cases even death for an enemy also
in many ways bungee gum can also act as
something of an ultimate shield as it
has been shown tanking both goto's
deadly coins but more importantly a
dodgeball infused with gon's rock attack
although once again bungie gum only
works in these cases because of hisoka's
superhuman abilities as he is able to
physically withstand the force being
flung at him and even then in the case
of the dodgeball it broke two of
hisoka's fingers to achieve and speaking
of fingers individual strands of bungee
gum can be generated from each of
hisoka's fingers as well as his hands
generally and feet however this does not
determine the maximum amount of strands
he is able to produce
hisoka's true limit is unknown but
during the heavens arena arc it was
stated that at one time he produced 15
different strands of bungee gum in his
match against castro most of which were
generated from a single hat and it
really is truly hard to describe just
how versatile this aura is in
combination with everything hisoka
brings to the table that is not related
to net watching hisoka use bungee gum is
like viewing a grand master of chess
thinking 10 moves ahead
laying down various traps and sinisterly
luring opponents straight to their doom
and it's particularly painful for an
opponent to deal with because hisoka
also shrouds hizora using in
meaning that it would require consistent
use of gyo to actually see what kind of
gum related traps he's hooker is laying
down but that in turn leaves the rest of
an opponent's body very vulnerable thus
providing hisoka with endless
opportunities to strike and this is
probably a good time to bring up that
rather frustratingly for the world at
large hisoka is more or less a master of
the basic and advanced applications of
nin as well we just flagged in there but
hisoka is probably most well known for
possessing one of the most sinister
invocations of ren that we've seen in
the series
although not the most sinister however
it is still well and truly capable of
producing the bloodlust phenomena and
another commonly wielded principle is
that of shu which hisoka uses to enhance
his playing cards to the point where
they become deadly deadly weapons in
fact with that in mind shoot is hisoka's
main win condition to damage or kill
opponents
usually kill but in many ways it's
actually much more important than bungie
gum and again this goes to show that
bungie gum in and of itself is nothing
but a supplementary hansu designed to
give hisoka endless and well-planned
opportunities to strike opponents with
his other skill sets but it would also
be a mistake to view bungie gum as
hisoka's main method of achieving these
advantages because he does have another
often forgotten about hatsu known as
texture surprise
and with this hisoka is able to apply
his aura to any kind of smooth surface
and transmute it to replicate the
properties of
effectively any substance he wants the
most basic example of this would be
replicating his own skin during his
match with castro thus giving the
impression that his dismembered arm had
been instantly healed however allegedly
hisoka can transmute his aura into more
than a thousand different substances
including skin metals fabrics and
minerals and i suppose one of the more
absurd invocations of this was during
the oak new city arc where hisoka used
texture surprise to replicate both the
paper and the ink which crawler used to
tell the fortunes of the phantom troupe
with his stolen lovely ghost writer
ability
and not only that but he did it
instantaneously and was able to produce
an entirely different fortune so texture
surprises not at all to be
underestimated with a strategist like
hisoka this ability is every bit as
useful as bungee gum
in fact it may be even more versatile
and that's nowhere near the full extent
of its madness and that's because in the
manga hisoka has reached a whole new
level of power by engaging in the
wonderful realm of post-mortem nen
during his battle with chrollo in
heaven's arena hisoka for the first time
in the series proved to be outmatched by
the planning capacities of the phantom
troop leader which i suppose does bring
up hisoka's one and arguably only
weakness in the realm of nine being that
he is so confident in his ability to
improvise that he will gladly meet any
opponent directly on their terms which
was a very
very bad idea in this case as crawler
thoroughly planned to deal with bungee
gun by collecting a maddening five nine
abilities which when used in various
combinations in this particular location
provided a hard counter to anything that
hisoka was capable of generating and as
a result hisoka was indeed killed in
heaven's arena but not before he did
something particularly interesting as
the brilliant strategist hears hisoka
saw his inevitable death well in advance
and with no other choice available he
elected to test the theory of
post-mortem nen which if you're not
familiar with the concept is an
invocation of nen that occurs after the
death of the user usually in response to
some sort of profound desire or emotion
and often times postmodern can linger in
the world as something of a permanent
effect
not so much this time though because
hisoka essentially issued a command via
bungie gum
where he said the following gum i
beseech you
spring to life after my death pumped my
heart my lungs stoked me all over to
revive me and because hisoka's death
would ultimately be caused by
suffocation due to being swamped by
about 200 puppet people amongst a giant
explosion this put hisoka's body in a
position where bungie gum was indeed
able to act on its master's last desires
springing hisoka back to life but that's
not quite all
because due to engaging in post-mortem
men hisoka's basic abilities also became
much more powerful along with his
revival for example he was now able to
use bungee gum to create prosthetic
limbs very very useful indeed since he
had lost both an arm and a foot in the
fight against crollow
not just that though the gun was also
capable of filling in for the flesh he'd
lost in the explosion and covered with a
delicious
layer of texture surprise hisoka all of
a sudden looked good as new and
furthermore hisoka also demonstrated a
much more advanced use of bungee gum
using a mission where he was able to
successfully trap and restrain machi and
while hisoka was competent in a mission
previously
being able to separate parts for zoro
here and maintain its extraordinary
strength is once again a whole new level
of insanity when it comes to this man
and quite honestly we still have yet to
see the full extent of his post-mortem
abilities with all of this in mind
though one thing that's not particularly
clear is how bungee gum
and texture surprise were developed this
is because hisoka is a character quite
deliberately shrouded in much much
mystery and yes i know there is that one
shot chapter by suishida which attempts
to give us hisoka's backstory but as
always i need to mention that that is
not currently canon and as of right now
all we know for a potential fact because
hisoka could just be lying i guess
is that his abilities were likely
inspired by two candies that he enjoyed
as a child which are implied to have
been named bungie gum and texture
surprise which i suppose does
very much play into hisoka's more primal
nature he is a man who seeks what he
believes to be the most basic pleasures
of life
much akin to a child's eternal focus on
attaining delicious candies but whatever
the case hisoka is a true rarity of the
nin world physically and mentally he is
an ideal vessel for the art form pushing
it to degrees that the more basic ori
users could only ever half-heartedly
dream of but at the same time hisoka is
quite modest with his nen usage electing
not to invest his aura in grand world
shaking abilities meaning that he is not
overly reliant on menus to serve his
purposes which is a trait that is
demonstrated by many of the greatest
transmuters in the series and
once again it just makes hisoka such a
pain to deal with because even if you do
somehow figure out his abilities before
landing into a bungee gum trap
it doesn't really help you all that much
because you still need to deal with a
terrifying superhuman murderer with an
infinite arsenal of ideas at his
disposal
mostly made possible by the simplest of
transmutations
because without hisoka bungie gum and
texture surprise are nothing
but in combination with hisoka they are
two of the most deadly and deceptively
simple hatsu
ever generated in this world but what do
you guys think please do leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you're
keen for some more hunt on content then
please to go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular hunter hunter glory
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review
and i'll see you next time